so this is my favorite new subclass this
is the Night Stalker it's the honors
first true support filled so we're going
to look at this take a little deep dive
so first up we have the grenades so it's
got spike or need so let's look that's a
pretty fun one it's a little tricky to
use but once you've gotten the hang of
that you can really set up some cool
plays I've got volleyball so this is the
hunter's new grenade it creates this big
horizontal wall that's an area denial
tool it's really powerful and really
really fun to use local visuals and a
good old classic vortex grenade so he's
got a bunch of will be like to think of
his track renewed so he can set up plays
with eric denial really easily for his
jumps we are going into hired job so we
got the super tall job better control
and triple jump i have time to go with
better control because i like to do a
strafing midair kind of gameplay it
gives you some cool triggy opportunities
and their first super shadow shot The
Night Stalker will actually summon this
void bow pull back a shot and when it
hits wherever it hits it'll sort of
build up lash out and grab bunch of
targets slowing them suppressing them
keeping them stuck and there's bunch of
fun little mods here for that so sharing
the damage across the tether lasting
longer being a little bit more reliable
and I'm queer to shoot it three times
basically so that's super fun so I
joined them up and we'll knock them down
exactly yeah so I'll go black hole so we
can make sure we get maximized roundup
knocked down for his melee we have the
smoke bomb so this is the hunter's new
little toy here you can throw that to
the saurian guys blind them and there's
lots of new mods for that as well also
venom to double down the damage factor
of the smoke bomb vanish and smoke this
one I was telling this one's my favorite
I love Batman yeah it's like the smoke
pellet is yeah this one's super great
for your teams like I said the nice
Locker is all about supporting his team
so you can actually take you and your
allies visible with smoke bomb here and
then snare so kind of playing on the
trap gameplay theme for your stats I
chose to double down on
recovery it's my style and since i'm
going to be supporting these guys i'm
going to be running a courage of the
pack which is another way to keep
supporting my team light of the pack is
another good way to do that and if you
want to be a solo kind of guy and focus
on Eric Nile you can run lockdown which
is a good way to double down on your
your traps as well and then over here
I'm gonna be running shadows x-shape
steps so i can dodge your bunch around
and i love dodge it super fun makes you
feel really agile but the other options
are predator which is basically another
trap mode kind of thing and keen scout
which gives me a lot more awareness with
my environment then that abated shutdown
that is pretty fun right effect oh right
and uh yeah of course yeah good to catch
their yes the artifact I'll be running
the mural desert of course that's my
favorite and I just had one most
breakfast actually so this one is yeah
totally doubling down on my void skill
set here so when melees will give me a
chance to get some worms alright and
Cosmo
you